il ya quelques jours alors que j'étais à
new york je vous ai présenté très
rapidement le au port et no 2 qui est un
des nouveaux smartphones de au pot de
cette année 2010 9 passes qui a eu
beaucoup de smartphones s'est opposé
talent elle est là sur ce deuxième
semestre
il vient de sortir deux smartphones
vraiment intéressant il ya le au port et
no2 et il ya le au port et nos deux
aides alors aujourd'hui on va se
recentrer sur le au port et naulleau qui
est juste là je vous parle du z
dans quelques jours ils sont très très
très très proche il ya quand même des
points de différence
il ya pas mal de choses à raconter de
celui dont je vous invite dès maintenant
vous abonner s'est pas déjà le cas comme
ça vous saurez tout sur ce au pot dreno
z
mais pour l'instant vous allez me dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire comment vous trouvez au port
et nos deux alors je sais il faut
prendre le temps de découvrir un petit
peu d'abord en vidéo parce que s'ils
voulaient marquer tout de suite eh bien
peut-être que votre avis rap hip aînés -
peuvent être dès maintenant me laisse un
petit commentaire serait ce que pour
faire un petit coucou ça me fait
toujours très plaisir voilà au port et
nos deux médailles avec une touche aux
affaires ça y allait
[Musique]
si on pouvait voulu jeter le doute en
tout cas sur le fait de choisir le bon
produit il n'aurait pas fait
différemment
regardez moi les deux boîtes sont
quasiment les mêmes alors aujourd'hui on
va se faire un comparatif n'est pas
l'objectif mais ici vous avez bien leur
ai no 2 et là vous avez le réno deux z
le z est caché par ici ils se
ressemblent énormément à une petite
différence près qu'à des revenir
chercher d'un peu plus près aux allées
voir ça se cache par ici là la petite
bille ici pour éviter sa veine trotter
qui situent en haut sur le z en bas sur
l'autre sinon c'est quasiment quasiment
la même chose il est petit disposition
différente mais sinon on est quasiment
sûr à leur place aux smartphones on a
donc ici le au port et no 2 le modèle
standard j'ai déjà montré quand j'étais
à new york plutôt sympa j'aime bien ce
dos je trouve ça original puis surtout
c'est différenciant c'est vraiment une
patte signé au pot et là vous avez le
réno deux aides alors la vraie
différence à se situe là lorsque vous
tenez vous à la petite bille la petite
bille là la petite bille et le cercle
lorsque vous allez le poser à plat et
bien ça va éviter que ça devienne
frotter savent créer un petit relief
c'est plutôt intelligent s'agit
effectivement de risquer de l'abîmer
alors ça crée un déséquilibre
lorsque vous posez votre smartphone et
bien voyez potentiellement il bouge un
peu mais c'est pas très grave
les deux smartphones se ressemblent et y
en a un qui à 499 et l'autre ya 349 vous
allez voir ya quand même pas mal de
différences entre ces deux smartphones
est justement celui là il fait quelques
promesses qui sont vraiment très
intéressante avec la gamme renault au
point nous propose des smartphone
orienté photo et là ils vont encore plus
loin avec ce modèle là c'est un
smartphone qui en plus orientée vidéo
souvent la vidéo c'est un peu le parent
pauvre du smartphone quant au capteur le
rendu est pas toujours génial pour avoir
un truc bien il faut arriver dans le
très haut de gamme
et là c'est intéressant parce qu'on
laissera straten à moins de 500 euros et
il fut une très très belles promesses en
termes vidéo avant de vous parler de la
vidéo on va commencer par se faire un
tour complet de cette petite bête et
vous allez voir que franchement elle est
très sympa la première chose que jamais
sur ce smartphone se son design je le
trouve plutôt bien différenciant est
vraiment réussie même si cette petite
bille et crée un certain déséquilibre
elle al'avantage d'être là effectivement
d'éviter que puissent l'abîmé
bien évidemment vous mettre une coque de
protection auquel cas vous n'aurez plus
tout problème si toutefois vous voulez
l'utiliser comme ça sans coque de
protection c'est possible il faut quand
même savoir qu'à l'arrière vous avez un
corps d'une gorilla glass 5 donc ça va
protéger mais s'il chute pensé à mettre
une protection parce que sinon vous
allez l'abîmé et pour ce faire vous
devrez up les coques de rhinau chili
l'estonie suite regardez-moi ça ça comme
c'est mignon
vous le prenez vous le glisser
délicatement à l'intérieur et là vous
avez un smartphone protégé qui ne craint
absolument rien et vous en avez une
deuxième hausse alors celle là si vous
n'aimez pas les faits carbone est bien
là et hop vous avez ça qui est aussi
très sympa un peu plus classique très
doué qui marche bien d'ailleurs vous
avez 10 % de remise avec le code
monsieur guérineau chine je vous ai mis
en bas dans la description n'hésitez pas
penser vraiment apte à protéger votre
smartphone parce que vous savez une
chute même si vous avez un compte dont
la glace 5 à l'arrière eh bien ça fait
toujours mal et à l'avant vous avez un
corning gorilla glass 6 pour le
déverrouiller vous allez petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous posez votre
doigt ça dérouille très rapidement
extrêmement actif donc ça s'est vraiment
bien j'aime beaucoup l'écran amoled 6,5
pouces
il occupe 93 dagen 1% de la face avant
résolution de 1400 par 1080 pixels à 400
pixels par pouce le duo est pas mal mais
pas où vous avez un seul haut-parleur
qui se situe juste là il est planqué si
vous avez un haut parleur mono pas de
haut parleurs stéréo là dessus donc pas
il perd immersif autant d'expériences
sonores à côté de ça il ya quand même
beaucoup de puissance organe est un peu
beaucoup de puissance et quand vous
pousser à fond et bien ça a tendance un
petit peu a saturé
bon on peut pas tout avoir pour profiter
la meilleure qualité faut utiliser cette
petite prise jack de levier plos high
resolution et là vous allez profiter
d'une qualité audio qui sera quand même
décuplé par rapport à ce que vous allez
voir avec le petit haut parleur ici côté
performances vous avez quelque chose qui
marche avec un snapdragon 730 g g comme
gaming c'est un processeur milieu de
gamme de qualcomm qui va venir apporter
plus de performance et il certifiait
élite gaming qualcomm vous avez 8 gigas
de ram 256 go de stockage
ailleurs sur un taux vous avez le score
de 250 9700 qui l'a classé juste à côté
du pic rodwell osman dragonne 730 g
c'est un snapdragon 730 e greg qui me
permettra d'avoir un peu plus de
performances on a un triple système de
refroidissement
grafite liquide et cuivre
je trouve pas qu'ils sauvent
particulièrement les performances sont
suffisamment de bonnes fait tomber
beaucoup de jeu je prends assez de
plaisir à y jouer ce soit des jeux comme
baby gym ça marche bien l'ol s'est
coloré si ce qu'on va pas rentrer
aujourd'hui dans des tailles de colo est
par contre tout ça tourne sous android 9
paille et ça marche merveilleusement
bien
il a une grosse batterie de cap il me
les opérateurs qui nous permet de tenir
deux jours facilement ça dépend bien
évidemment toujours des designers vendre
est tranquille et j'ai toutefois vous
pêchez et bien vous avez de la bvk
charge 3.0 alors je suis pas là pour
vous hypnotiser dans la vo charge 3.0
servira pour recharger très très
rapidement on appelle une lueur volonté
de 0 à 50 %
c'est rapide c'est pratique ça marche
bien l'idée de cette grosse batterie
tête vous charge si vous en mettez plus
vous posez pas la question du jeu dira
il faut que je leur charge on est soir
donc d'un matin ils soient prêts et
charges est disponible non on se pose
tranquille on se relaxe on se détend on
se regarde un petit film on fait ce
qu'on veut on travaille faites ce que
vous voulez ça vous regarde
lorsque vous êtes plus beaucoup de
l'atria vous prenez votre book charge
vous brancher et ça va très vite quand
on s'intéresse à la partie photo c'est
là que ça devient très très très
intéressant vous avez quatre capteurs
photo à l'arrière
je pense que ça vous le voyez vous avez
un premier capteur de 48 méga pixels
c'est là sony mx 5 186 qui a des clio iv
pixels en oc est excellente pour les
photos de nuit vous avez un deuxième
capteur de 8 mégapixels lui celle ultra
grand-angle 216 degrés vous avez ensuite
un téléobjectif de 13 mégapixels
tu me permettra de faire un zoom optique
x 2 1 ou l'hybride fois 5,15 numérique x
20 et en dessous vous avez une petite
caméra de 2 mégapixels qui est là pour
notre portrait pour les faits évoqués çà
vous permet d'avoir un équivalent de 16
à 83 mm pour me refaire vos photos sans
absolument aucun problème là 48
mégapixels ouvre à f 1.7 l'allier
mégapixels f 2.2 la 13 mégapixels f 2.4
et la 2 mégapixels f 2.4 également
tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez une caméra
statique et planck est ici de 16
mégapixels tu ouvre à f 2.0
c'est le fameux aileron de requin tous
apportent quelques avantages que ce soit
en photo ou en vidéo laisse nous venons
très directement dans l'eau s comment ça
marche j'arrive à il ya plein de choses
intéressantes et je montre le résultat
juste après vous avez donc votre mode
photo x x 2 x 5 ultra grand-angle et
vous laisser appuyer là vous choisissez
votre gradient comment vous voulez
maître mot est bien ou mal an il n'y a
pas grand-chose à venir filmer les
apports une table blanc
on va pas bien mais ça marche bien photo
caméra principale l'a48 mégapixels avait
complètement stabilisée dès que vous
arrivez sur la fois 2 est bien là vous
n'avez pas de stabilisation et d vous
arrivez x 5
là vous avez une stabilisation hybride
ça bouge pas du tout et plus vous montez
et bien ça ne bouge toujours pas alors
là je suis vraiment en forme un groupe
vraiment un petit peu cherché l'histoire
mais vous met en faut dix ça marche pas
je lie jusqu'en fin disent vous avez une
qualité qui est quand même vraiment bien
et ultra grand-angle aussi marche quand
même relativement bien a noté vaut
effectivement votre mode photo vous avez
le mode portrait vous avez également un
mode vidéo c'est un petit peu long pour
passer d'un up de l'un à l'autre il faut
s'armer d'un peu de patience
il faut quand même une petite seconde up
très facilement et ensuite vous
retrouvez nord-est doit d'ici nuit
panorama experts photographier par
intervalles ralenti stickers et google
dance dans votre mode appareil photo
comme je voulais montrer pour avoir
ultra-grand-angle vous venait le
chercher en descendant mais vous pouvez
la voir si d'autres manières s'est fait
comme ça d'un point de vue logiciel
c'est assez marrant vous l'avez vous
cliquez ici et là vous arrivez sur votre
ultra-grand-angle alors bon on dirait
que ça fait doublon vous l'avez là vous
l'avez là bon ok pourquoi pas je dirais
que le plus intéressant va se trouver
ici au niveau de la vidéo parce que
c'est vraiment la promesse de ce
smartphone vous avez déjà une
stabilisation optique sur un capteur
principal
donc lorsque vous ne prenez que vous
courrez vous déplacer comme par exemple
assure cette vidéo est bien beau fixe
est extrêmement stabiliser c'est déjà
très très bien stabilisé ça c'est la
stabilisation optique mais lorsque vous
voulez rajouter un peu plus et bien vous
allez cette petite icône la la claque
vous cliquez sur une stabilisation
électronique sacre hop un peu plus dans
l'image par contre ça va stabiliser
davantage ça c'est vachement bien
[Applaudissements]
lorsque vous filmez qui a pouvoir venir
zoomer x 1 x 2 x 5 et même l' ultra
grand-angle après voulait s'appuyer et
c'est vous qui choisissez vous
transition pourrait par contre le tarif
je viens je joue le jeu des zooms je
fais comme je veux ça c'est très
pratique on va vraiment un changement
d'objectifs entre l'ultra grand temps
les le capteur 48 mégapixels mais ça
marche assez lâche on vient de par
contre si vous switchez up directement
avec la stade avec tonic et bien vous
avez un seul capteur vous ne pouvez pas
faire de zoom dézoom bon c'est pas très
grave parce que je venais chercher
quelque chose de relativement
particulier vous voulez vraiment
beaucoup de stabilité
vous avez également un autre bloqué en
vidéo vous venez claque vous cliquez là
vous avez un mode portrait cloud
arrière-plan vous choisissez ici votre
pourcentage de flou une femme voulait
régler vous pouvez même l'utiliser avec
les différents os x 2 x 5 mais pas ultra
grand-angle et si ce n'est clairement
pas ce qui marche le mur vidéo parce que
si je joue beaucoup voyaient au niveau
du contour des cheveux il ya tout ça se
faire un petit peu fou rester fixe faut
pas bouger
là ça vous fait un flou qui est pas mal
mais moi reste fx je sais pas trop faire
moi je trouve ça tu peux avoir la
bougeotte et c'est vrai que le rendu est
pas complètement dingue
bon c'est assez rigolo pour certaines
personnes qui sont assez immobile
pourquoi pas pour moi jamas eh bien
l'expérience vidéo qui est faite
là-dessus
le fait d'avoir cette stabilisation pour
moi c'est vraiment bien c'est ça nous
rapproche un peu si vous voulez des
actions en cas alors on n'est pas sur
une action comme on est sur un
smartphone mais lorsque vous voulez
filmé dans la rue ou qui se passe quoi
que ce soit et si vous n'avez pas de
stabilisation derrière ça craint un peu
le fait de combiner la stabilisation
optique et la stagnation électroniques
sont ça vraiment bien parce que pour que
vous êtes chose qui est vraiment
stabilisé même si vous à dire cros paix
un peu dans l'image en activant la
stabilisation électronique savons plus
être améliorée grâce au fait d'avoir le
gyroscope 800 hertz en plus ce que vous
allez venir filmer vous avez un petit
micro qui est planté juste là qui est
assez directionnelle alors c'est pas un
truc incroyable on va pas avoir d rendu
professionnel mais je dirais qu'on peut
revenir
bloguer un peu de temps en temps ou
capter des ambiances pourquoi pas
s'appelle bien et en plus vous avez de
la réduction devant une foule déchaînée
plein de trucs vraiment que vous avez
une application qui est sympa pour le
montage c'est celle là qui est planqué
en bas saut loupe alors ce loupé ça vous
permet de créer des vidéos très très
très facilement on va sélectionner
quelques plans un plan là un plan là un
plan là un plan là un plan là un plan là
ça va me générés automatiquement une vie
l'ingénieur une vidéo de trente deux
secondes je peux choisir le format l'âge
et le format 16/9 si je veux plutôt
format instagram 9 saisit enfin j'ai pas
mal de possibilités donc regarder la
samhd1 la vidéo j'appuie sam a créé une
vidéo 32 secondes
je dois venir la customiser met les
titres faire ce que je voulais ça me
facilite la vie ça ne mâche le travail
alors l'idée variés plan stabiliser
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment cool je
peux changer mon format la voyais ça m'a
pris différents points donc ça me fait
un truc un petit peu bon voila il pas de
trucs complètement dingue
néanmoins si je viens changé de format
que je le passe comme ça ça ne marche
pas ce que ça devient accro paix dans
mon image sale adapte et je trouve que
au final le rendu est assez marrant là
je viens les 10 tgv raccourcir les plans
là je peux faire ensuite comme je veux
peut venir choisir la couleur de mon
image les sous titres la musique soit
une musique que j'ai dans mon téléphone
soit la petite musique de démo soit
carrément pas une musique peut même lane
est muet si je le souhaite
une fac m'ont rendu me plaît et que tout
est ok et bien j'appuie sur généré
saddam généré ma vidéo assez rapidement
en quelques secondes et ensuite je peux
venir la publier la partager très
facilement youtube gmail mais dans mes
photos faire ce que je veux bon c'est
assez rigolo par contre cela me mettre
un petit logo se loupe pour montrer que
vous l'avez créé avec l'application
alors on n'est pas du tout sûr un outil
professionnel c'est pour faire quelques
petites vidéos si vous voulez aller plus
loin pour créer vos propres vidéos et
les applications qui existe d'autres
applications que celle là l'idée en tout
cas c'est de pouvoir partager très
facilement rapidement sur différents
réseaux sociaux
en tout cas moi ce que j'aime beaucoup
dans ce smartphone est ce que je trouve
vraiment très intéressant c'est la
proposition de valeur vous avez en
termes de photos vidéos ça marche bien
c'est complet on peut faire beaucoup de
choses quelque chose qui est stabilisée
on va pas aller aussi loin que ce qu'on
pourra voir avec le réseau avec le zoom
x 10
on n'aura pas autant de puissance mais
au moins on a suffisamment puissant
quand on est beaucoup de jeu pour avoir
des vidéos et des photos de qualité pour
les partager sur les réseaux sociaux
un grand écran de qualité pour moi le
smartphone en tout cas de smallville est
vraiment bien réussi par an
je vous montre le rendu des photos pour
vous rendez bien compte de toute façon
on savait qu'on peut maîtriser les
photos donc ce n'est pas surprenant que
le rendu soit qualité là dessus là on
est sur le capteur principal
une fois deux fois cinq ans jusqu'à fois
vingt bus très grand-angle continue ici
capteur principal soit 2 3 5 et là on va
jusqu'à fois vingt élus ultra
grand-angle regarder le ciel
c'est très juste très bien maîtrisée sur
cette photo là le hdr marche
merveilleusement bien là il est en mode
automatique et s'étaient activés
là c'est pareil retenu avoir au ciel où
on voit très bien les détails les ont
bien maîtrisé
pareil lorsqu'on arrive sur une fois 5
ça marche bien bon dit qu'on arrive sur
le foie rein honnêtement c'est très
poussif c'est pas terrible
il ya beaucoup de bruit mais bon c'est
là alors pourquoi pas qu'elle soit
principal soit 2 x 5 x 20 jutra
grand-angle chasseurs principal là j'ai
bien pris en photo le ciel on voit que
le hdr marche très très bien on lit bien
le panneau on voit bien le ciel on voit
bien le détail des nuages x 2 x 5 bon ça
fonctionne à peu près là c'est vraiment
nul chercher avec le x 20 c'est pas
extraordinaire mais ça fait toujours son
petit effet et l'ultra grand temps
qu'ils marchent aussi quand même
relativement bien on voit bien sur le
panneau on a cru bien à lire donc ça
c'est cool
l'heure est sur un petit contre-jour
photo normale x 2 x 5 mm x 20 ans va
plus rien c'est vraiment horrible et
d'ultra grand-angle officielle avec hdr
qui maîtrise parfaitement bien qu'ils
aient vraiment très très bon x 2 x 5,3
20-15 ultra-grand-angle ce résultat au
niveau de la food nuit vraiment bien on
a un beau rendu au niveau des détails
gestion des lumières qui est très
correct c'est très dynamique horse et
les photos que j'ai pris sur ce que j'ai
testé à new york parce que je les prie
aime à new york lorsque vous venez
souhaité que le capteur principal ça
marche bien l'ultra grand angle est un
peu moins parfait au niveau de la
colorimétrie mais ça marche vous venez
d'où mais c'est bien alors quand on
s'approche beaucoup trop près avec le
zoom x 20 c'est beaucoup moins justes
mais dans l'absolu en tout cas je trouve
que pour voir une pas plus que les
francophones à moins de 500 euros le
rendu est vraiment hyper qualitatif
alors il ya aussi un mode qui existe et
le mode nuit totale la voyez j'ai pris
une photo
tel quel il fait nuit on doit absolument
rien et lorsque je mets une exposition
longue de 45 secondes
on arrive à sortir quelque chose parce
que ça vous fait un petit voyez un petit
point rouge
il en voit de la lumière mais vraiment
ça n'apporte absolument rien je pense
qu'il faut quand même un peu de lumière
pour qu'on arrive beaucoup pas exposé à
sortir un truc est pas mal sur un ton
expression qui est très très long mais
sinon ça ça absolument rien et quant au
mode portrait il est pas mal
il fonctionne plutôt bien il a un petit
peu de mal et regardez là il m'a très
bien et toi les doigts les doigts de ce
côté là aussi ça marche bien brossé dans
l'ensemble plutôt bien mais avec les
cheveux en eau
il a un peu plus de mal entre les
couleurs de la fiche et mes cheveux tout
un peu ton sur ton est là elle a eu un
peu du match bon on n'est pas sur un
stand rigole du 155 plus donc c'est pas
étonnant
néanmoins ça fait quand même le taf on
est sur un smartphone qui a du bluetooth
5.0 qui a du nfc et vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir soit une double
carte nanosims soit une certaine aussi
une carte microsd moi je le trouve
vraiment très très très cool
au port et nos deux dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous ambac au mandatement
vous le trouver est ce que vous aimez
toute la partie photo qui mise en avant
tout la partie vidéo et ce smartphone il
a plusieurs atouts
déjà le tout premier c'est son écran
très bel écran amoled
il ya des reflets pas si c'est bel et
bien de vos rencontres il est vraiment
top surtout il est complètement dégagé
donc pour le côté multimédia c'est
vraiment extrêmement pratique vous
prenez absolument pas la tête vous
pouvez l'utiliser pour jouer alors même
si on n'a pas le maximum de performance
ou faut tourner je dirais allait
peut-être 80 90 % même un peu plus des
jeux du plastoc ce conflit qui a
constitué ya tellement de jeux soit les
stores une photo est quasiment tous les
jeux du plastoc donc au moins vous êtes
tranquille vous avez quand même
suffisamment performant si vous avez une
batterie qui est bonne 4e ils opéreront
c'est quand même relativement cool de la
recharge extrêmement rapide
là vous propres - 0 donc ça s'est
vraiment bien et surtout toute la partie
photo toute la partie vidéo qui est un
des gros plus de ce smartphone
il est je dirais que avec le au port et
no x 10 où ils vont très loin en à ce
qui se fait de mieux en terme de
performance
avec ce modèle là on n'a peut être pas
ce qui va se faire de mieux en terme de
performances rencontres on va continuer
à travailler la partie photo et continue
à travailler la partie vidéo c'est pour
moi le gros focus de ce smartphone c'est
vraiment le côté un peu plus
nouveauté c'est la partie vidéos dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est-ce que vous utilisez la
vidéo sur nos smartphones et est ce que
vous pourriez l'utiliser pour moi là
dessus ils vont draguer les créateurs de
contenu ceux qui aiment bien les beaux
instagram avec les très grands écrans
qui regardent du contenu mais qui aussi
ancrée donc la boule regarder et elle a
rien voulu créer que ce soit en photo
que ce soit en vidéo il doit si vous
êtes d'accord avec moi en bas en
commentaire et d'ailleurs si sot pour
renault 2 vous intéresse vous a mis un
lien en bas dans la description quant à
nous on se retrouve dès demain on
continue à parler de teck et très
bientôt d'ici quelques jours pour parler
de son petit frère pixi plus d'un tour
dans son sac
à demain ciao